all right let's take some questions that
don't have anything to do with Donald
Trump directly although the second
question invariably the answer does have
to do with Donald Trump at least in part
first question is from Julia Julia says
hey guys aren't some stereotypes rooted
in truth I think the answer is
definitely yes some stereotypes are
rooted in truth in the sense that they
were created as as stereotypes based on
the behavior of a small number of people
of a particular group designation or
whatever the case may be but I think the
issue with stereotypes is even if they
are rooted in truth insofar as there's
some action or characteristic of a group
of people that was identified and say
mmm you know X group is why because of
what person Z was observed doing there's
sort of two major problems with that
number one it's not true about everybody
that is part of that group so therefore
what do we really gained by stereotyping
in the first place and number two
oftentimes those stereotypes are used to
justify either discrimination or various
types of prejudice against all members
of that group so III don't deny to Julia
that yes there are stereotypes that are
rooted in truth but the real question is
number one does that tell us anything
about how we should be treating people
that are part of a particular population
and number two it often ignores history
so for example like I'll take a
stereotype that applies to a group that
I'm part of right so there's a lot of
stereotypes about Jews and banking and
control of financial institutions and
bla bla bla bla bla the conspiratorial
aspect is crazy right so there's this a
conspiracy between Jews to work together
to take control of Finance and banking
or whatever that that's just it's crazy
to begin with but there's also
historical reasons that have everything
to do with discrimination against Jews
which explain to us why you sometimes
see higher concentrations of individuals
from certain groups in certain
industries if you look back historically
there are many profession
that Jews were not allowed to have due
to discrimination and prejudice by its
very nature that concentrated Jews in
certain industries that they were
allowed to I mean think about the
insanity of that allowed to participate
in and then now it becomes a negative
stereotype so I I add what's your sense
of this I don't disagree with what Julie
is saying I think it's just very very
dangerous to say because some
stereotypes may be rooted in truth
therefore that justifies acting in a
particular way or categorizing people
based on those stereotypes yeah I think
that's exactly right and I think your
example was perfect there I mean it can
be rooted in truth that can also be
rooted in history and I think you lay
that out well I mean and usually when
you talk about stereotypes there's this
undertone of something being racism
racist or sexist or whatever it may be
it doesn't necessarily have to be that
way no I mean you could come up with the
idea that frat boys play foosball
together and then you know based on that
make assertions that oh because you're
in a frat you play foosball whatever it
may be but it's just not intellectually
honest I don't think to characterize
yeah someone's activity based on who
they are my brother had a really really
good line that he has started yeah I've
experienced many times where I'll be
there when someone makes some kind of
horrible generalization about some group
and my brother has started using a line
which I've now started using which is
really really good at sort of getting to
the heart because a lot of times people
will say these generalizations these
stereotypes and they're sort of framing
it as if it's just an honest observation
of the way X group of people tends to
act and a really good question is when
people say that instead of reacting
defensively you say and I've tried this
and it's really interesting what happens
you say that's interesting that you've
noticed that what do you think that says
generally about the group of people and
that will instantly if the person has
half a brain cell will get them to say
that's a good question and it
immediately gets to the root of what is
the bigger picture that they have of X
group so just like as an example right
if someone says you know every time I
walk around
on the streets I just see tons of
Hispanic people waiting around outside
hardware stores trying to get day labor
that's interesting what do you think
that says more broadly about Hispanic
people and then hopefully you get
something who's at least connected
enough to their own thoughts to say well
you know I think to me it confirms that
Hispanic people are inherently lazy and
then you can immediately say interesting
and why would they be waiting around to
work if they're inherently lazy and it
opens the door maybe to challenging some
of these beliefs it's really an
effective tool
yeah and that stereotype in particular
is often contradictory too because
people will criticize or allege that
Hispanics are lazy and then on the same
token criticize that they're taking our
jobs away you gotta love that
ya know and and that's in particular
that's why I chose that example so ok
that's my answer Julia I hope that
that's been somewhat informative